mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wer kultur
houston viel vergnügen
seit der verschärfung der korona
vorschriften ist auch das kulturleben
wieder bedruckt betriebe kämpfen ums
überleben
und doch es wird gespielt denn kultur
systemrelevant es ist herzenssache dass
die sachen passieren kommt eine
herzensangelegenheit für alle
kulturschaffenden jetzt in kulturplatz
heute gehen wir aus willkommen auf dem
kulturplatz wenn ja wie vermissen das
schunkeln an den konzerten das lachen in
den theater rängen
und ja es gibt sie noch die kulturhäuser
die weitermachen
ein haus wo der widerstand gegen die
aktuell schwierigen umstände geradezu
kultiviert wird ist das el lokal in
zürich eine kulturinsel zwischen see und
limmat hier legen wir heute abend
auch hier gilt die verschärften
maßnahmen maximal 50 menschen und er und
20 uhr ist schluss
und doch im el lokal wird gespielt heute
steht die zürcher in die sängerin die
erzähler hier auf der bühne und feiert
ihre plattentaufe doch jetzt ist zuerst
soundcheck angesagt
[Musik]
die modelle ihr neues lokal die
allerletzte insel das könnte so als wäre
hier vor der harten realität verschont
blieben ja so ist es leider nützt also
ganz sicher nicht das gibt uns genau wie
alle anderen auch wir haben die zeiten
sind aber vorbei zehn jahren biergarten
des wunderschön sie dort sich seine
beiden flüsse
darum sehen wir die alte letzte dienst
haben sich besser überlebt als andere
oder ungerecht ist als andere kultur
euro kostet die möglichkeit einen koran
bei irland so lange müsse zur tour wie
noch nie ja wenn zwei minuten komplett
ca über das haupt jahren haben jetzt ein
konzept macht wie handwerker hand etwa
3100 regler mit drei musikern
tontechnikern kommen wenn man ein
konzept noch kommt auf youtube kohle
gegraben wird das haben wir probiert und
jetzt wohl sorgen dass halt wieder
mitzumachen
ich mache konzert ich glaube gibt es
einfach für 50 mann stoppte 250 das
rechnet sich niemals rechnet sich nicht
für fußball haftmann texas zusatzkonzert
verloren gemacht haben um 50 lied das
sind total 100 aber musik momente pedro
tontechnik meisterklasse alles zusammen
also dass garten hat seine ganzen wieso
machen das trotzdem
ja zum einen ist das gewitter oder also
außer betrieb und damit das zeichen
setzte zeigt dass man als künstler ist
natürlich sie waren da ruft der
möglichkeit das war mit einer sicherheit
werk neben diesem thema sind die freunde
ja vita x bit labs ist lange
freundschaft zwischen lokalen und sei
dabei das ist purer idealismus gehört
aber zum glück aber beziehungs steht
also für die stadt zürich will pop
kredit beantragen konnte und zürich
ja das ist wenigstens in china zur
stunde ist paul strand hat sich franz
winter oder wahrscheinlicher ist aber
dass wird so also uns gar keine musik
machte und zustand völlig neues kann
aber das ist immer eine perspektive von
katja durchhalten bis zum letzten wir
sozusagen die an klubs machen also
weiter wie hier
andere sind bereits geschlossen wir
haben uns umgeschaut
das kulturlokal doktor in olten seit dem
oktober sind vier veranstaltungen bis
auf weiteres eingestellt kulturkarte
der betrieb überlebt jetzt nur noch dank
der bar und auch da fließen die
einnahmen spärlich durchhalten ist
lebenswichtig ist der konkurs und dann
hoffen die sache natürlich die gläubiger
hatte und bedanke handel bis zu mir die
nicht einfach locker sitzen weil andere
sie zerbrach sie gästen für faktoren ort
wo sie mit der grund warum also sollte
bliebe aber sollte sie oder auch hier
kamen und für die er wenn etwas ganz
ruhig aber es nimmt zufolge sieben um
anzukommen
das bezeugen ja auch für zwei von
hundert veranstaltungen pro jahr
jetzt also auf 9 denn bei 30 personen
die im kanton solothurn zugelassen sind
ist das spielen nicht rentabel
zwar zählt jetzt jedes bier
der ausschank schafft aber ein weiteres
dilemma
das belegt sind sie dank kommentare das
gab das macht es extrem schwierig
gross auch im theater am gleis in
winterthur wird trotz beschränkungen
auch gespielt
[Musik]
hier findet aktuell das tanzfestival
statt
das sei er dem kulturbetrieb schuldig
sagt geschäftsleiter andreas gruber sehr
wichtig ist das gewinnstreben und
wünschen noch weiterhin kein duft heute
dass man eine perspektive biete dass man
auch das publikum das modell bis
computers hat immer noch durch natürlich
nehmen so viel dafür stark eid umso
größer mehrheit euro verpflichtet
gegenüber stadt und kanton aargau körper
werden vertrag mit denen wir so viel wie
möglich kultur anbieten und natürlich
auch für heute mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern 700 veranstaltungen mussten
im kanton basel-stadt von november bis
ende jahr abgesagt werden
auch das sommer casino treffers
geschäftsleiter mich gehrig wurde
überrumpelt als es nach einem
angelaufenen konzertsommer plötzlich
wieder beschränkungen auf 50 personen
gab
[Musik]
behörden entscheidet zwingen die
betreiber neue lösungen zu finden
im sommer kasino soll eine
weihnachtswelt draußen den verlust bis
ende jahr abfedern
im sommer 2009 10 war die welt noch in
ordnung
da tanzten 600 leute ausgelassen zu
flirrenden gitarren klingen
jetzt ist es hier still mich gehrig und
sein team sind in der kurzarbeit der
konzertsaal wurde zum corona konformen
arbeitsplatz umfunktioniert
viele der kultur lokale überleben dank
subventionen so auch das pallas in st
gallen ein ehemaliges kino
die unterstützung ermöglicht das auf
sparflamme gespielt werden kann
denn eines ist klar es muss weitergehen
glaubt kultur ist systemrelevant
wenn es kulturelle leben und die
gesellschaft im wickeln die pandemie
inspiriert dazu über neue formen der
kulturvermittlung nachzudenken ist
eigentlich entsorgt spieler um auch in
sachen machen inhalt generieren so manch
andere plattform schaffen wo machen
kulturvermittler egal ob mit oder ohne
publikum
es braucht kreativität um eine krise zu
überleben
und es braucht die unterstützung der
öffentlichkeit konsumieren ist angesagt
nicht nur bier sondern auch kultur mit
abstand natürlich
na wir zähler ab lautet darf jeder sieht
was bedeutet das alles bedeutet enorm
viel das muss wir haben und machen sie
natürlich extrem erschwerte bedingungen
aber wir haben jetzt zwei jahren
schaffte unserer arbeits und wenn man
dann das album release sony ist ist das
auch wirklich so schlimm
sie engagiert sich der schweizer
musikszene im frühling lockt taxistand
sie am essen vorgeschlagen dass vermehrt
schweizer musik spielte dass es über
tura brachte pittsburgh des inneren hat
das ja also das radio hat deutlich der
anteil von der schweizer musik erhöht
und das ist einfach sehr wichtig für uns
wir natürlich wieder ein name der mit
besonders gutes programm gespielt werden
sein lokal ist ein ganz besonderer ort
für sie ihre verstorbene christoph barth
ist da aber immer noch sehr präsent sich
was bedeutet für sie dazu
das lokal ist es bei diesen wichtigen
ochs ist im herzen so preuß und dann
kriegst vier vormittage stattfinden wo
in europa sind sie machen das wahnsinnig
kurz musikprogramm und sie schaffe man
zusammen ganz fest
das ist nicht selbstverständlich dass
die da oben auf der bühne steht noch der
große persönliche krise noch immer
großer verlust jetzt auf der bühne
was bedeutet das
das ist schon extrem großer moment für
mich und ich bin aber wahnsinnig dankbar
dass ich dann mitteilen
ich glaube für alle musiker ist es so
dass sie gerne anteile besonderes
natürlich was neues gibt für mich ist es
vielleicht noch spezieller wählen so
viel bedeutet für mich die arbeit als
dieser videoclip gedreht wurde an 10a
die erzähler noch nichts vom drohenden
schicksalsschlag vier jahre lang blieb
der club unter verschluss zu groß die
parallele zu ihrem leben
[Musik]
das mit dem stil live video ist grafik
controller
[Musik]
plötzlich und er hat so eine neue
bedeutung bekommen zone zwischen
schlager die vorahnung galt ihren
damaligen lebenspartner dem über die
landesgrenzen hinaus bekannten
cartoonisten christoph button 2016 starb
unerwartet in einem plötzlichen
herzversagen tief versunken im
trauerprozess bedeutete ihr die musik
lange zeit überhaupt nichts mehr bis sie
sich mit klassischen requiems
beschäftigte empfinde ich glaube mich
auch so kräftigen kiefern art musik über
den intellektuellen analytisch anfang an
mit musik einer wg und nach amerika
nicht so kummer metall karte geschrieben
jetzt liegt das album vor das lockt
requiem greetings to andromeda ein
schillernder spannungsbogen über ganze
18 songs
[Musik]
das ganz konkrete gefühl totaler
vermissen was auf mit einem völliger
wahnsinn von vermissten und babysachen
erträgliche jahr die sondern liegt sein
schätzen die gefahr dass auch zum
ausdruck bringen also sehen wir die
tauchlehrer carolis das hpc vorbereitet
und nun vom schreck
das projekt die band als heilendes
ritual mit dem bassisten michael lehner
hat nadja zähler einen neuen
lebenspartner gefunden und der album ist
ein berührendes werk über verlust und
den weg zurück ins leben
[Musik]
neben
ab sofort ist sie ihre platte im handel
erhältlich
und nun zu einem ganz
ein thema deswegen corona etwas in
vergessenheit geld machen sie sich auch
gedanken über ihren ökologischen
fußabdruck also ich habe mir schon viele
gemacht schon vor corona war fliegen kam
ein thema mehr
ich besitze kein auto esse kein fleisch
ja mit dieser bilanz war ich eigentlich
ganz zufrieden bis ich einen artikel
gelesen habe von matthias plus der
behauptet das café brutal schlecht sei
für die persönliche ökobilanz
jetzt erscheint das erste buch des
wissenschaftsjournalisten matthias plus
sie haben rein gelesen
überschwemmungen
anhaltende dürreperiode schmelzende eis
kappen die katastrophe naht
die gute nachricht wir können etwas tun
auch mit kleinen schritten etwa beim
geliebten morgenkaffee dieser hat von
allen getränken den größten ökologischen
fußabdruck mit einem einfachen trick
lässt er sich verkleinern
die maschine steht das ist eine fraktion
kraft von mir aus kannst du sogar noch
leben sie und warum man so was bringt
das ist richtig es geht darum mehr strom
muss er gebraucht und einem jetzige das
stimmt zwar aber nicht hauptsache ist
produktion von produktion von graf ich
mache die residenten fußabdruck und in
dem training ich mich dazu weniger
kräfte zu buche
der wissenschaftsjournalist matthias
plus lebt im kanton aargau abseits der
stadt ohne auto dafür mit fahrrad mit
seinen 75 ideen was jeder und jede gegen
den klimawandel tun kann traf er vor
einem jahr im magazin des tages
anzeigers den nerv der zeit
die reaktionen darauf waren
überwältigend preis erhielt hunderte von
mails von der angeregten leserschaft
[Musik]
einfach klar einfach information
also ich nehme das so ist das hat mir
wirklich selber überrascht dass einfach
so zur kenntnis
nun ist ein buch daraus entstanden eine
art klima ratgeber mit kurzen kapiteln
sehr anschaulich geschrieben und ohne
moralischen zeigefinger
drei beispiele aus dem buch essen das
klimafreundlichste nahrungsmittel
überhaupt ist die sehr energiereiche
haselnuss
waschen auf den trockner verzichten
diese energiefresser verbrauch doppelt
so viel strom wie die waschmaschine
verpackungen die totale vermeidung von
verpackungen ist oft kontraproduktiv es
roth forrest matthias plus geht es in
seinem buch darum aufzuzeigen was man
konkret im alltag tun kann
weniger auto fahren viel weniger fleisch
essen aufs fliegen verzichten
diese klima tipps sind bekannt
interessant wird es bei unverdächtigen
klimasündern etwa dem reis und fleisch
vom vegetarier hat viel mehr co2 ausstoß
pro kalorie aussetzung beispiel hervor
oder andere getreide das lied trat als
reese im wasser ab und wird um die den
bären sich nachher bakterien die die
metallerzeuger das mit dauern wird
ausgestoßen instrument eines ganzen
staates klimagas bei vielen dingen gibt
es eigentlich keine alternative zum
verzicht beim reis haben wir nochmals
glück gehabt ein problem und das ist ja
bedeutet series und david im trockenbau
arbeit dh entstanden viel weniger methan
und das ist besser fürs klima da mache
ich jetzt da der senior researcher das
problem beim kampf gegen den klimawandel
ist nicht dass wir zu wenig wissen
sondern dass wir zu wenig unternehmen
sieht war eigentlich ökologische stadt
sind aber nach dem auto kalt doch sich
ganz anders frau das ist schon sehr
menschlich das muss man ihm vorwerfen
und ist krasser ist eigentlich das de
lüt wo wirklich grünen danke oder grün
wahlfrauen menschen untersucht die sind
wahrlich der größte abdrucken oder
menschen am meisten flügen
auf das fliegen zu verzichten ist
zumindest im corona ja nicht schwierig
aber kann man denn als einzelner
überhaupt etwas bewirken den eigenen co2
ausstoß auf null tonnen pro jahr senken
und 250 aber das ist gar nicht möglich
oder aber man zwischen null und gar
nicht machen zwischen null und
resignation und lokale gezeichnet ganze
zwischen oder und und wichtig ist
einfach dass man bedenkt wo ein großer
impact and dass man dort aus setzt und
da kann man sehr viel aufzuholen einfach
die dass man sagen macht matthias plus
zeigt das ist leichter als man meint
denn so wie es im zeitalter von corona
normal geworden ist dass wir uns öfter
die hände waschen
so müsste es normal werden dass wir
klimafreundlich leben
sein leitsatz hilft dabei weniger ist
weniger
[Musik]
von der eigenen verantwortung nun zur
verantwortung der gesellschaft
der terroranschlag in wien traf eine
stadt mit liberalen werten mitten ins
mark wir haben uns die frage gestellt
wie entsteht islamistische
fundamentalismus inmitten einer
aufgeklärten gesellschaft und wie sehr
ist die lage in österreich mit unserer
in der schweiz zu vergleichen
es war unfassbar vier tote 22 verletzte
im zentrum von wien trauer und schrecken
saßen tief
kaum jemand hat in österreich mit einer
solchen tat gerechnet
in einem land mit höchster
lebensqualität in dem sich die bürger
sicher fühlten
doch österreich gilt in europa neben
belgien als das land mit den meisten
islamistischen kämpfern die nach syrien
ausreisen wollen
hier gibt es keine pornos wie in
frankreich
und trotzdem radikalisieren sich junge
muslime
es hat mich schockiert aber es hat mich
nicht überrascht will in grad in wien
hätte wie radikale moschee und es helfe
tschetschenien es historische grenze
viel bürokratie zwei gruppen machen
eigentlich zu groß für den dschihadisten
saida keller-messahli kennt die szene
der radikalen islamisten in der schweiz
und arbeitet in wien auch für die
integration gefährdete muslime
droht in österreich macht mir enorm viel
für die integration das heißt dass sich
institutionalisiert dass wir die
migranten hilft fuß fassen
aber bedingt ich natürlich dass sie sehr
spezielle identifizieren
mit der wahl vom land und tetra balletts
und genau das machen ab
aus diesem grund wurde in österreich
schon vor fünf jahren ein neues islam
gesetz eingeführt es gibt dem staat das
recht radikaler moscheen zu schließen
und unerwünschte imame auszuweisen
gleichzeitig aber entscheiden
muslimische verbände wie der islam an
den schulen unterrichtet und wie die
religion interpretiert werden soll
das bekommt auch ibm absatz zu spüren
er lehrt an der uni wien islamisches
recht und sagt der einfluss religiöser
verbände auf die lehre nimmt zu
es gibt definitiv ein klima der
einschüchterung deshalb ich persönlichen
in zwei jahren die ich jetzt an dieser
universität bin sehr massiv erleben
müssen
wir haben es hier mit einem engstirnigen
ghetto islam zu tun sie sehen dass eben
auch in den muslimischen verbänden es
ist kein kleines radikalisierungsprozess
von wenigen extremisten wir haben es
hier in der großen breite mit leuten zu
tun die den liberalen verfassungsstaat
den die säkulare gesellschaftsordnung
zutiefst ablehnen in österreich gibt es
700.000 muslime doch nur ein bruchteil
ist in den religiösen verbänden
organisiert wie kann es sein dass
religionsvertreter die universitäten
beeinflussen der verdacht die verbände
wollen einen streng religiösen islam in
der gesellschaft etablieren
ich glaube nicht dass die herrschaften
mit den ideen die die organisierte
muslime vertreten offen gewalt
profitieren oder sie auch persönlich gut
heißen
das möchte ich nicht aber sie
widersetzen sich ganz explizit den
notwendigen anpassung an den säkularen
verfassungsstaat und damit sind sie die
geistigen brandstifter solchen tuns
wie sieht es in der schweiz aus
unternehmen muslimischen dachverbände
genug gegen radikale moscheen wie die
anno moschee in winterthur eine
berechtigte frage
auch weil der wiener terrorist
verbindungen zur winterthurer
dschihadisten hatte der sprecher der
islamischen föderation relativiert der
sich heute so stark immer vorgeworfen
wird so quasi irgendwelche jeder die
kahle imame wo ganz frei und fröhlich
durch die ganze schweiz tingelt und
überall jedes gedankengut und hass
predigt verbreitet dass man geschockt gh
dass ich auch nicht akzeptiert aber das
passiert dann im einzelfall und muffins
jetzt zum glück wieder nach hause dass
man das auch verhindert oder die reise
führt aber das ist ja so dass ich wieder
so dass dann wirklich alle so tikrit
doch genau um solche einzelfälle geht es
wie können die verbände diese verhindern
und dafür sorgen dass die moscheen keine
platz bieten für ausgrenzung für hass
auf alles was anders ist wie können sie
sicherstellen dass das auslegen ihrer
religion den grundwerten unserer
gesellschaft entspricht den verband drei
sind dann werdet ihr natürlich sofort
konfrontiert mit dem dann würdet uci
suspendiert werde wenn wir dann gespürt
so sache passierte diene das hilft
keinem wenn immer der verband so moschee
sind zunahme sind wo der ex gedankengut
prediger türen doch sarah keller
messahli fordert mehr eine reflektion
der gewalt schon im text des korans
radikalisierte gereckt muss man für die
jugendlichen so einer ruhe schaffen wo
sie heute kritisch über der koranische
text rede und darüber wie es klappt und
interpretiert wird mit müsse mache den
die quali siegen nur mit kulturen
begegnen
und darum geht's darum geht's nicht da
geht auf jeden fall nicht in der moschee
gegen die radikalisierung hilft der
muslime nur eine kritische
auseinandersetzung mit der eigenen
religion und die garantie auf freie
meinungsäußerung
denn toleranz wird nicht nur von der
westlichen gesellschaft ein gefordert
sondern auch von der muslimischen
glaubensgemeinschaft
und hermann wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
im lokal in zürich einer der wenigen
kultur ins und in diesen tagen feiert
erzähler jetzt ihre platte ihre neue
platte in
im neuen lebensabschnitt und das ist ein
echter mutmacher nächste woche da geht
es bei uns um weibliche
selbstermächtigung und um sexualität ich
freue mich wenn sie dann auch wieder mit
dabei sind gleich jetzt geht es weiter
mit dem report der markt gute nacht
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
tourismus
[Applaus]